infant distress means your baby is
having difficulties knowing what to look
for will help you know if your baby is
in distress your baby may have breathing
problems such as retractions grunting
and apnea retractions are unusual
breathing movements with each breath
your baby's chest muscles pull in the
skin around the bones
grunting is a noisy breathing sound your
baby may grunt to cut air in the lungs
grunting may sound like snoring or
singing apnea is a condition in which
your baby pauses breathing for 15 to 20
seconds
then continues breathing
you may notice changes in your baby skin
two common findings are conditions known
as cyanosis and jaundice cyanosis is a
blue skin color you can usually see it
around your baby's lips chest and
stomach this blue color means that the
oxygen level in the blood may be too low
cyanosis may mean there is a problem
with the baby's lungs or heart
jaundice is an overall yellow skin color
it happens when a substance called
bilirubin builds up in the blood most
babies have some jaundice that appears
more than 24 hours after birth if left
untreated severe or long-lasting
jaundice may cause brain damage
it's important to check your baby for
these signs of distress
immediately contact a member of your
health care team if you notice any of
these warning signs